Hi, I'm Max and a work as an assistant psychologist in the Learning Disability Service in West Yorkshire. Like most people working in psychology, I'm slowly but surely working myself up to that seemingly impossible goal of getting onto the clinical doctorate. With that end goal in mind, I thought I'd have a look at what's out there and see what books might be helpful for this. I came across Marianne's book, The Clinical Psychologist Collective, and decided that this would be a great great. for me to help me on my journey. I found Marianne's book really informative, most insightful. I especially liked how the stories reassured me that you don't need to be academically perfect
嗨，我是Max，在西约克郡的学习障碍服务中心担任助理心理学家。像大多数从事心理学工作的人一样，我正缓慢而坚定地朝着那个看似不可能的目标努力，那就是进入临床心理学博士课程。怀着这个最终目标，我想看看市面上有什么书能对此有所帮助。我偶然发现了玛丽安（Marianne）的书《临床心理学家合集》（The Clinical Psychologist Collective），并决定这对我的旅程将大有裨益。我发现玛丽安的书非常有启发性，见解深刻。我特别喜欢书中的故事，它们让我确信，你不需要在学术上完美无缺
to become a psychologist, and that as long as you have good interpersonal skills, such as compassion and empathy, you will get there. I would highly recommend this book to all aspiring psychologists, nor so those who want to know a bit more about the world of clinical psychology and made me want to work in that field one day. Since I finished reading Nobody's Child by Virginia Jafray, I've been sitting with something I can't quite shake. Whilst I expected the book to stay with me because of what happened in it, that's not actually what's been on my mind. Instead, I've been noticing what I was drawn to and what I wasn't. And if I'm honest, that doesn't always sit entirely comfortably. Because it's made me question what we're actually trying to understand
才能成为一名心理学家，只要你具备良好的社交技能，比如同情心和共情能力，你就能达到目标。我强烈向所有有志于成为心理学家的人推荐这本书，也推荐给那些想更多了解临床心理学世界并希望有一天能投身该领域的人。自从读完弗吉尼亚·贾弗雷（Virginia Giuffre）的《没人要的孩子》（Nobody's Child）后，我一直被某种挥之不去的感觉困扰。虽然我预料到这本书会因为其中的内容而让我印象深刻，但那并不是我真正介意的事情。相反，我一直在关注自己被什么所吸引，又对什么感到排斥。老实说，这种感觉并不总是让人完全舒服。因为它让我质疑我们到底在试图理解什么
when we hear stories like this. And how easily we can end up asking questions like, well, why did she stay? Why didn't she leave? So I thought as a clinical psychologist, we could take a look at some of this together. Hi, welcome along to Psychology Actually. I'm Dr. Marianne Trent, a qualified clinical psychologist. Now, I can't be alone that I enjoy reading books
当我们听到这样的故事时。我们是多么容易最终问出这样的问题：好吧，她为什么留下来？她为什么不离开？所以我想，作为一名临床心理学家，我们可以一起探讨一下其中的一些问题。嗨，欢迎来到《心理学实际上》（Psychology Actually）。我是玛丽安·特伦特（Marianne Trent）博士，一名合格的临床心理学家。我想，喜欢阅读与心理学、心理健康、创伤和健康相关的书籍的人，肯定不止我一个。
that are relevant to kind of psychology, mental health, trauma and wellness. Growing up, I'm fairly sure in my late teens, early 20s it was, I was reading books by Dave Peltzer like a child called It, that kind of vibe. So I was intrigued when posthumously Virginia Drafray's book, Nobody's Girl, was published. In case you don't know her name or the name of the book, let me give you a little bit of information. I'm going to be talking about things as facts because there have been legal processes that took place that determined that was the case. So Virginia Roberts Jafray might well ring a bell for you if you think about Andrew Mountbatten Windsor, who was previously Prince Andrew. And it was Virginia or Jenna, as she called herself and is called in the book, who had been trafficked to Prince Andrew at the time.
在成长过程中，我很确定在我十几岁到二十出头的时候，我读过戴夫·佩尔泽（Dave Pelzer）的书，比如《被当作狗养大的孩子》（A Child Called It）那种风格的作品。所以，当弗吉尼亚·贾弗雷的遗作《没人要的女孩》（Nobody's Girl）出版时，我很感兴趣。如果你不知道她的名字或书名，让我为你提供一点背景信息。我将把这些内容作为事实来谈论，因为已经有法律程序确定了这些情况。如果你想到安德鲁·蒙巴顿-温莎（Andrew Mountbatten-Windsor），也就是以前的安德鲁王子，弗吉尼亚·罗伯茨·贾弗雷这个名字可能会让你想起什么。正是弗吉尼亚，或者她自称并书中被称为詹娜（Jenna）的人，当时被贩卖给了安德鲁王子。
and I'm sure that now the name rings a bell if it didn't already. So Virginia or Jenna had ended up crossing path with Galane Maxwell and with her partner at the time, Geoffrey Epstein. Now, the book is about trauma, it is about grooming. It is about, you know, sometimes the worst in humanity where people start to not treat each other as if they're humans, as if they're humans, as if they have value for anything other than what they want them for.
我相信现在这个名字即使你之前不知道，现在也应该有印象了。所以弗吉尼亚或詹娜最终与吉丝兰·麦克斯韦（Ghislaine Maxwell）以及她当时的伴侣杰弗里·爱泼斯坦（Jeffrey Epstein）有了交集。这本书是关于创伤的，是关于诱导（grooming）的。它是关于，你知道，有时是人性中最糟糕的一面，人们开始不再把彼此当作人类来对待，不再把对方视为拥有除他们所利用价值之外的任何价值的人。
And that can be challenging, that can be triggering. I think the first thing to say is that it is a book of two halves. So the first half is about her upbringing and essentially what unfolded, what happened to her. And the second half is about justice and getting everything to lay a little bit flatter and ultimately holding people accountable. And I would like to level with you. As a human and as a psychologist, both parts of me found the first half much more interesting. You know, it's this human desire to learn and to find out information and to kind of,
这可能会让人感到挑战，也可能会触发创伤。我认为首先要说的是，这是一本分为两部分的书。第一部分是关于她的成长经历以及本质上发生在她身上的事情。第二部分是关于正义，让一切真相大白，并最终追究相关人员的责任。我想坦诚地告诉你，作为一个人类和一名心理学家，我个人觉得第一部分更有趣。你知道，这是一种人类学习和获取信息的渴望，以及一种……
I like reading magazines like That's Life magazine. I don't know if you guys ever read any real life stories, but I love. like knowing about people's experiences and how they felt at particular times and what mechanisms they might have drawn upon to help them to survive tricky things. I personally was less invested in the justice and also I think less invested in her family that she went on to have afterwards. And that's, you know, it doesn't always sit that easy because, you know, you think you want to be this kind of balanced clinician that's, you know, being a justice warrior. But I am also human. So I would love your thoughts if you've read the book. What did you think about the two halves?
我喜欢读像《这就是生活》（That's Life）这样的杂志。我不知道你们是否读过真实生活故事，但我喜欢了解人们的经历，了解他们在特定时刻的感受，以及他们可能运用了什么机制来帮助自己度过棘手的事情。我个人对正义部分的投入较少，而且我认为对她后来组建的家庭的投入也较少。这，你知道，并不总是那么容易接受，因为你认为你想成为那种平衡的临床医生，那种正义的斗士。但我也是人。所以如果你读过这本书，我很想听听你的想法。你觉得这两部分怎么样？
How did they stack up for you? So I think some of the psychological mechanisms going on here is that humans are drawn to intrigue and kind of curiosity and maybe sometimes always drawn to a shock factor, you know, so I'm always thinking about kind of compassion focused theory and the way that our brains are wired and put together. And if you find that angle interesting, please do check out the episodes that I did with Professor Paul Gilbert, where we go into compassion focused therapy in more detail. And I think when we recognise that we've got that more of an interest, you know, our attention is held more by that. We shouldn't shame ourselves for it. We shouldn't judge ourselves for it. we as a species are kind of a survival first species that we need to be paying attention to things that might pose us risk or someone else as well. So it is just the way that our brains are
它们对你来说有什么影响？所以我认为这里面存在一些心理机制，人类会被阴谋和好奇心所吸引，有时甚至会被冲击因素所吸引。你知道，所以我一直在思考同情心聚焦疗法（Compassion Focused Theory）以及我们大脑的运作方式。如果你觉得这个角度很有趣，请务必查看我与保罗·吉尔伯特（Paul Gilbert）教授合作的剧集，我们在那里更详细地探讨了同情心聚焦疗法。我认为当我们意识到我们有这种兴趣时，我们的注意力会被它吸引。我们不应该为此感到羞耻，也不应该为此评判自己。我们作为一个物种，本质上是生存优先的物种，我们需要关注那些可能对我们或他人构成风险的事情。所以这只是我们大脑的运作方式。
wired up. I think one of the other things that struck me was how the experience of trauma can kind of force us to reprioritize things that we might not have done had we not experienced them. So what I'm meaning here is that a lot of the time, Virginia or Jenna, was away from her family as she was trying to sort all these legal processes. She was often in different parts of the country from them and, you know, that priority being able to choose that over being with her family in a more present day-to-day capacity. It can't have been easy for her family either, but it did feel like the trauma had forced her to reprioritise the justice over the importance of spending that time with her family. And I think maybe that's the desire to kind of do some meaning making
我认为另一件让我印象深刻的事情是，创伤经历如何迫使我们重新排列优先级，如果我们没有经历过这些，可能就不会这样做。我的意思是，很多时候，弗吉尼亚或詹娜在处理所有这些法律程序时，不得不远离家人。她经常与他们身处全国不同的地方，你知道，能够选择这样做，而不是在日常生活中与家人在一起。这对她的家人来说肯定也不容易，但这确实让人感觉创伤迫使她将正义置于与家人共度日常时光的重要性之上。我想也许这就是那种想要在我们的经历中赋予意义的渴望，
in our experiences when something awful has happened to us. There can be that sense of something needs to count. You know, this needs to have happened for a reason. There needs to be more emphasis on this, more highlight on this, so that this didn't just, happened to me in vain so that other people can take note and so that important conversations and thoughts happen to make it less likely that this will happen to someone in future so interestingly even this morning as I was on social media I saw that the local police force to me had been doing some what they called stings on hotels and and taking young people into hotels with alcohol.
当可怕的事情发生在我们身上时。可能会有一种“事情必须有意义”的感觉。你知道，这件事情的发生必须是有原因的。需要对此有更多的强调，更多的关注，这样我就不会白白遭受这些，这样其他人可以引以为戒，这样重要的对话和思考能够发生，从而减少未来发生类似事件的可能性。所以有趣的是，即使是今天早上，当我在社交媒体上时，我看到我当地的警察部队正在对酒店进行他们所谓的“钓鱼执法”，带着年轻人和酒精进入酒店。
So the older person was carrying alcohol and the older person would say to the younger person, turn your phone off. And then they were trying to pay in cash and they were trying to book hotel rooms. And this is supposed to set alarm bells ringing for the sign of trafficking or grooming. And actually three, I think, of the five people,
所以那个成年人带着酒精，会对年轻人说，把你的手机关掉。然后他们试图用现金支付，并试图预订酒店房间。这应该为人口贩运或诱导的迹象敲响警钟。实际上，我想五个人中有三个，
called the police immediately. And obviously it was the police doing the sting anyway, so I'm hoping that was revealed. But there were, I think, two people who did allow this hotel room to be booked. And I think it is the learning from stories like this, from cases that then are hopefully trickling into our own narratives, the narratives of crime prevention agencies and kind of social services that are really getting us to think about, you know, really being more conscious and intentional and that we can be empowered to ask questions. I think as we're working in mental health settings as well, it really can be, you know, we need to give us as permission to ask questions, to not assume that people in front of us are always going to tell the truth and to be
立即报了警。显然，这本来就是警察在进行钓鱼执法，所以我希望这被揭露了。但我想有两个人确实允许预订了这个酒店房间。我认为正是从这样的故事中学习，从那些希望渗透到我们自身叙事中的案例中学习，犯罪预防机构和社会服务机构的叙事确实让我们开始思考，你知道，真正变得更加自觉和有意识，我们可以有权提出问题。我认为当我们也在心理健康环境中工作时，这确实可以，你知道，我们需要给自己许可去提问，不要假设我们面前的人总是会说实话，并要
compassionately curious and respectful. And this crops up in physical health settings as well, that we need to be trying to make sure that the clients in front of us are not at risk, but aware that they might not be telling us all of the information because of fear from someone that might hurt them or because they are conflicted or groomed or feel like it's not safe for them to do that. So yeah, like that idea of compassionate curiosity and learning from the stories of others, I think for me feels really powerful. And as a mother, I found it really tricky. When during the second half of the book, she describes losing her youngest child, her daughter for a bit when they were at a wildlife park because she'd just taken her eye off her and she'd wandered off and then I think
怀着同情心去好奇和尊重。这在身体健康环境中也会出现，我们需要确保我们面前的客户没有处于危险之中，但要意识到他们可能因为害怕伤害他们的人，或者因为他们感到矛盾、被诱导，或者觉得这样做不安全，而没有告诉我们所有的信息。所以，是的，那种同情心好奇心和从他人故事中学习的想法，对我来说感觉非常强大。作为一名母亲，我发现这真的很棘手。在书的后半部分，她描述了在野生动物园时，因为她一时没看住，她最小的孩子，她的女儿走丢了一会儿，然后我想
she eventually found her playing with wallabies or something. And it really made me think about the evidence that suggests when someone has been abused, they are less likely to be able to keep their own children safe because they might not follow some of the safety precautions that people who have not been abused would have done. And I think that's a really powerful idea as well. So not to shame or blame people, but just to be aware of those mechanisms. And when we're working with people who have been abused, it's actually really important We support them to make optimum decisions that keep themselves and their family safe in future. One of the trickiest aspects is the level of abuse that she experienced from her father
她最终发现她在和袋鼠之类的动物玩耍。这真的让我思考那些证据，这些证据表明当一个人受到虐待时，他们不太可能保护好自己的孩子，因为他们可能不会遵循那些没有受过虐待的人会采取的一些安全预防措施。我认为这也是一个非常有力的观点。所以不是为了羞辱或责备人们，而是要意识到这些机制。当我们与受过虐待的人一起工作时，实际上非常重要的一点是，我们支持他们做出最优决策，以确保他们自己和家人在未来安全。最棘手的方面之一是她从小受到父亲
and from one of the neighbours growing up when she was a child. And then actually in her adult life, she reconnected with her father and ultimately with her mum too and really wanted to have. her father know her children and be in her life and that is a hard one to understand and I suspect some of the mechanisms that that kept her in the grooming situation with Maxwell and Epstein are around here as well and we're talking about attachment you know wanting to be part of something wanting to have someone know us and see us and be able to share information about our heritage and we We see this time and time again with people who've had really difficult upbringings.
以及邻居之一的虐待程度。而在她的成年生活中，她与父亲重新建立了联系，最终也与母亲重新建立了联系，并且非常希望让她的父亲认识她的孩子并出现在她的生活中，这很难理解。我怀疑让她陷入麦克斯韦和爱泼斯坦诱导局面的某些机制也与此有关，我们谈论的是依恋，你知道，想要成为某件事的一部分，想要有人认识我们、看到我们，并能够分享关于我们血统的信息。我们一次又一次地看到这种情况发生在那些成长经历非常困难的人身上。
Sometimes that desire to be part of something really drives the bus and is favouritised and prioritised over being part of nothing and being part of maybe just your own family or you know, making you feel vulnerable, unloved, uncared for, which are obviously some of the deeper early wounds that have been set in motion. And there is the reparenting that often happens when people have experienced. abused, that they want their own children to have a different experience. And so maybe she wanted her children to have a different experience of her dad and of her mum.
有时那种想要成为某事一部分的渴望确实占据了主导地位，并且被优先考虑，而不是成为“无”的一部分，或者仅仅成为你自己家庭的一部分，或者你知道，让你感到脆弱、不被爱、不被关心，这显然是一些更深层的早期创伤。人们在经历虐待后经常会发生“重塑父母”（reparenting）的过程，他们希望自己的孩子能有不同的经历。所以也许她希望她的孩子能对她的父亲和母亲有不同的体验。
But also it's that longing and hoping for a different outcome that describes kind of being very watchful and really wanting to make sure that they weren't alone together. And that level of threat and distress that must have been going on at that time to then have all of that still outweigh the desire to kind of to emancipate, to say, actually, I'm not, I'm not having you in my life. We're not, we're not doing this and it's not okay. What happened. But, you know, I think, yeah, those desire, the desire to repair and reconnect and ultimately to be loved, that can be so very powerful. And I think, you know, the overarching question, that people have about the situation is, well, why did she stay? You know, she wasn't handcuffed,
但这也是一种渴望和希望得到不同结果的心态，这描述了那种非常警惕、非常想确保他们不会单独在一起的状态。当时一定存在的那种威胁和痛苦程度，竟然仍然超过了想要解放自己、说“实际上，我不会让你出现在我的生活中，我们不会这样做，这不对”的渴望。但是，你知道，我想，是的，那些渴望，修复和重新连接的渴望，以及最终被爱的渴望，那可以是非常强大的。我认为，你知道，人们对这种情况的总体疑问是，好吧，她为什么留下来？你知道，她没有被戴上手铐，
she wasn't restrained. She was free to come and go, to go from where she was living, and then to come back when she was called. And I think, you know, this is where the nuance really is kind of apparent and there's, it's incredibly complex, isn't it? And people, you know, absolutely begin to think that that's their worth, but also when people are being paid for something, then that becomes a job, doesn't it? And when you've got a job, you can kind of have that sunk cost fallacy. Well, you know, at least I've got a job and I'm being paid. And if I've been doing it for this long, it will be hard to get a job and people will notice the gaps on my CV and they'll wonder where I've been and what I've been doing. We can almost invalidate ourselves really by staying in situations
她没有被束缚。她可以自由来去，从她住的地方离开，然后在被叫到时回来。我认为，你知道，这就是细微差别真正显现的地方，而且这极其复杂，不是吗？人们，你知道，绝对开始认为这就是他们的价值，但当人们因为某事而获得报酬时，那就会变成一份工作，不是吗？当你有一份工作时，你可能会有那种“沉没成本谬误”。好吧，你知道，至少我有一份工作，我正在拿工资。如果我已经做了这么久，很难再找工作，人们会注意到我简历上的空白，他们会想知道我在哪里，在做什么。通过留在那些可能感觉具有破坏性的情况中，我们几乎可以否定自己。
might feel damaging. And I think there's also complex mechanisms at play here with with possible dissociation. So in order to do things that your mind doesn't want you to do, but you're being asked to do by someone with your body, then sometimes we'll dissociate from that, especially if you are being fed and clothed and looked after and paid recently well and kept in, you know, good standards, kind of luxury standards, living a luxury life going to desert islands and kind of meeting hugely influential people, that lifestyle can be hard to quit. And it does muddy the water, doesn't it? You know, especially if someone's been abused when they were younger, then we're not
我认为这里还存在着复杂的机制，可能涉及解离（dissociation）。所以为了做一些你的大脑不想让你做，但被某人要求用你的身体去做的事情，有时我们会从中解离，特别是如果你被喂养、穿衣、照顾，报酬相当不错，并保持在，你知道，高标准，那种奢侈标准，过着奢侈的生活，去荒岛，并结识极具影响力的人，那种生活方式可能很难放弃。这确实让情况变得模糊，不是吗？你知道，特别是如果某人在年轻时受到过虐待，那么我们不是
comparing someone that's had a very stable, solid existence of being loved and adored. and being able to talk about things are challenging and having that be responded to, that was not her experience as a child or as an adolescent. And when you've been raised in an abusive situation, then your own unique sense of worth and value can be affected. So when someone is looking upon you favourably, telling you that you're a good girl,
在比较一个拥有非常稳定、坚实的存在，被爱和崇拜，并且能够谈论具有挑战性的事情并得到回应的人，那不是她作为孩子或青少年的经历。当你在一个虐待环境中长大时，你对自己独特的价值感可能会受到影响。所以当有人以赞许的眼光看着你，告诉你你是个好女孩，
that you're, you know, that you're beautiful, that you're doing things really well, that also can be really, really tricky to start saying no to. And of course, the very important point here is that her younger brother, whom she adored, had been threatened. So if she was going to tell anybody about what happened to her or what was happening to her, then, you know, bad things would happen. And when you do have someone that adores you in your family,
你很漂亮，你做得很好，开始对这些说“不”也可能真的非常非常棘手。当然，这里非常重要的一点是，她深爱的弟弟受到了威胁。所以如果她要告诉任何人关于她身上发生了什么或正在发生什么，那么，你知道，坏事就会发生。当你家里确实有一个崇拜你的人时，
then, of course, that leverage over you is going to, hold really a great deal of weight indeed. I would love your thoughts on this. What have you thought to this episode? What's it evoked for you? Have you read Nobody's Girl? Are you intrigued to read it in future? I would love to know what you think of it.
那么，当然，这种对你的筹码将确实具有很大的分量。我很想听听你的想法。你对这一集有什么看法？它唤起了你什么感受？你读过《没人要的女孩》吗？你未来有兴趣读它吗？我很想知道你的想法。
If you like this style of diving into books that are kind of psychologically relevant, then please do take a moment to go over to YouTube if you're not already watching on YouTube and check out my psychology behind the story series. This is my first solo podcast episode for quite some times. It's really nice to connect with you in this way. If you enjoy hearing me talk about complex human emotions and processes, I think you might also really like my exclusive members-only content podcast, which is called Inner Work.
如果你喜欢这种深入探讨心理学相关书籍的风格，那么如果你还没有在YouTube上观看，请花点时间去YouTube查看我的“故事背后的心理学”（Psychology Behind the Story）系列。这是我相当长一段时间以来的第一期个人播客节目。能以这种方式与你们交流真的很好。如果你喜欢听我谈论复杂的人类情感和过程，我想你可能也会非常喜欢我的独家会员专享播客，它叫《内在工作》（Inner Work）。
And you can dive into that as a free three-day trial on Apple. You can join directly from Captivate, and you can join on YouTube too. There's details in the show notes and please let me know if you've got any questions, if you've got any ideas for future topics for the podcast, I would love to receive them too. Hello, my name is Veronica Kassova. I live in Edinburgh and I just graduated with a master's in psychology of mental health. Marion recommended me the clinical psychologist collective when I was networking on LinkedIn and I must say I love it. It is one of a kind. It's like a
你可以在Apple上通过三天的免费试用深入了解它。你可以直接从Captivate加入，也可以在YouTube上加入。节目说明中有详细信息，如果你有任何问题，或者对播客的未来主题有任何想法，请告诉我，我也很乐意收到这些建议。你好，我叫维罗妮卡·卡索娃（Veronica Kassova）。我住在爱丁堡，刚获得了心理健康心理学硕士学位。当我在LinkedIn上建立人脉时，玛丽安向我推荐了《临床心理学家合集》，我必须说我喜欢它。它是独一无二的。它就像一个
into the lives of people on the path of becoming a psychologist. The stories are unique, honest and filled with a kind of intangible wisdom only personal storytelling can uncover. A common thread in the stories I valued most was to be compassionate not only with others, but with myself too. Also, not fixating on becoming a psychologist, but enjoying life, growth, and the final result of will come as a byproduct. Marian, thank you for taking the time to collate all the stories. The book is a true gem, and I think every aspiring psychologist should have a copy on their shelf. Thank you. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
通往成为心理学家道路上人们生活的窗口。这些故事独特、诚实，充满了只有个人叙事才能揭示的那种无形智慧。我在最珍视的故事中发现的一个共同点是，不仅要对他人的痛苦感同身受，也要对自己宽容。此外，不要执着于成为一名心理学家，而是享受生活、成长，最终的结果会作为副产品自然到来。玛丽安，谢谢你花时间整理所有的故事。这本书是一颗真正的宝石，我认为每一位有志于成为心理学家的人都应该在书架上放一本。谢谢。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。